Bonjour!
C’est le retour des Gentes Dames Badass,
et pour coller au dernier Chroniques de Prof
sur les mers on va parler d’une femme qui
les a parcourues.
Les mers.
J’ai déjà parlé de Jeanne de Belleville,
une pirate du XIVe siècle, et d’Anna Maria
Merian, une naturaliste du XVIIIe.
Jeanne Baret, dont on va parler aujourd’hui,
rassemble à la fois le fait d’être une
femme qui dit merde aux conventions de son
époque et de se passionner pour le naturalisme.
Et puis pour une fois qu’on sait beaucoup
de choses sur une femme qui n’est absolument
pas issue de la noblesse, on va pas se priver
d’en parler.
Jeanne est née le 27 juillet 1740 près d’Autun,
en Bourgogne.
Son père était journalier, c’est à dire
un paysan sans terres qui faisait un peu tous
les travaux des champs qu’il pouvait.
Il était aussi probablement analphabète.
Sa mère était femme au foyer, probablement
un peu nourrice à ses heures, probablement
occupée par tous les petits travaux qui pourraient
lui permettre de nourrir la famille.
En grandissant dans une famille paysanne du
XVIIIe siècle, elle n’a pas du avoir une
enfance facile.
On ne connaît pas beaucoup sa jeunesse:
elle apprend à lire et écrire, commence
à travailler jeune comme gouvernante et perd
ses parents, on ne sait pas comment.
De là elle part travailler à Paris mais
perd un procès contre l’un de ses employeurs,
ce qui la ruine du peu qu’elle avait, et
est finalement engagée comme gouvernante
par Philibert Commerson en 1764.
Là on va un peu s’arrêter sur Philibert
Commerson, puisque c’est le personnage le
plus important de sa vie: Philibert est
médecin, mais surtout passionné de botanique.
Il tient des tas d’herbiers et passe ses
journées à courir la campagne charolaise
à la recherche de nouvelles espèces à cueillir.
Sa femme est morte en couches deux ans plus
tôt, et il appelle donc Jeanne au secours
pour qu’elle soit la gouvernante de son
fils.
Rapidement, elle devient plus qu’une simple
gouvernante et se passionne à son tour pour
les plantes: elle lit les herbiers et les
livres de Commerson, il lui enseigne ce qu’il
sait, et elle l’assiste dans ses recherches:
elle répertorie ses documents, classe les
végétaux qu’ils ramassent… Et rapidement,
ils deviennent aussi probablement amants.
L’affaire commence à se savoir quand elle
tombe enceinte, à la fin de l’année 1764:
là, c’est le scandale au village, elle
refuse de nommer le père de son enfant même
s’il s’agit certainement de Commerson,
et ils décident donc de partir s’installer
à Paris dans deux logements différents.
Le fils de Philibert est confié à un oncle
et on n’en entendra plus jamais parler.
De son côté Jeanne accouche d’un garçon
qui est placé à l’assistance publique,
mais il ne vit que quelques mois.
De toute façon, ça faisait un moment que
Philibert voulait monter à la capitale pour
commencer à se faire connaître: là il
rencontre d’autres botanistes, des scientifiques,
et notamment un ami astronome qui le recommande
auprès du roi.
C’est grâce à ça qu’on lui propose
en 1766 de participer à l’expédition de
Bougainville, et là nous allons donc faire
un point… Bougainville!
Bougainville est un officier de marine mais
aussi très intéressé par la géographie.
Il sort tout juste de la guerre de Sept Ans
pendant laquelle la France a perdu le Canada,
et il avait bien réussi à conquérir les
Malouines pour le roi mais elles sont finalement
cédées aux anglais.
Il est donc un peu déçu, et convainc le
roi d’organiser cette expédition déjà
parce qu’il lui doit bien ça et aussi parce
que ce serait la première expédition française
autour du monde, et que ça en jetterait face
aux anglais.
L’expédition a donc surtout un but politique,
diplomatique et scientifique: on ne pense
pas encore trop à la colonisation, et grâce
aux idées des Lumières qui circulent beaucoup
à cette époque les explorateurs se montrent
très curieux et respectueux envers les peuples
rencontrés.
Et on s’intéresse aussi énormément à
toutes les sciences durant cette période.
Bref, Commerson hésite à partir parce qu’il
a une santé fragile.
Il se ferait bien accompagner par Jeanne,
parce qu’elle est devenue assez indispensable
pour l’aider dans ses travaux, mais les
femmes sont interdites à bord des navires
du roi.
Il accepte finalement et part embarquer à
bord de l’Étoile, qui doit aller rejoindre
Bougainville en Amérique du Sud, et là,
mais qui donc apparaît?
Jean Baret, un homme assez mince, imberbe,
qui se présente comme le valet payé par
le roi pour assister Commerson.
Et puis comme Commerson a le mal de mer, il
demande à ce que son valet dorme dans sa
cabine, hein, au cas où.
Il a la chance d'avoir une cabine rien que
pour lui pour entreposer ses herbiers, avec
toilettes privées, ce qui est bien pratique
pour son valet.
Si vous n’aviez pas encore compris, c’est
Jeanne Baret qui a caché sa poitrine et s’est
déguisée en homme.
Le 1er février 1767, le voyage commence.
Et pour que vous compreniez bien à quel point
Jeanne et Philibert jouent un jeu dangereux,
c'est surtout lui qui risquerait la Bastille
s'ils étaient découverts: Jeanne était
une femme, donc forcément pas responsable
de ses actes.
Philibert, en revanche, aurait pu être accusé
d'avoir embarqué une femme à bord pour son
bon plaisir, et ça, c'est mal.
A la même époque, l'explorateur Kerguelen,
qui a découvert les îles du même nom, quelle
coïncidence, a été condamné à six ans
de forteresse pour avoir embarqué sa maîtresse
de 14 ans à bord, déguisée en valet de
chambre.
Jeanne n'est pas dans la même situation puisqu'elle
est surtout là pour assister Philibert dans
ses travaux, il la surnomme même sa bête
de somme.
Sympa.
Mais on sait grâce au testament de Philibert
qu'elle était payée pour ça.
Le voyage ne commence pas très bien, puisque
dès les premiers jours le navire prend l'eau,
il faut pomper régulièrement.
De son côté Philibert a le mal de mer, mais
l'équipage arrive quand même à rejoindre
les côtes du Brésil puis Rio de Janeiro
où les attend Bougainville avec son propre
navire.
Là ils font escale un mois, et ça permet
à Jeanne et Philibert d'explorer la ville
et la nature autour.
C'est un sacré choc culturel pour Jeanne
qui n'a connu que la France: elle découvre
le sucre, le café, et c'est là que que Philibert
fait la découverte du bougainvillier qu'il
nomme en l'honneur du chef de l'expédition.
A bord du navire se trouvait aussi François
Vivez, un chirurgien qui parle régulièrement
de Jeanne:
Après Rio ils reprennent leur route vers
le Sud, pour atteindre le détroit de Magellan,
mais sont obligés de s'immobiliser deux mois
dans l'embouchure de la Plata à cause du
navire qui prend toujours l'eau.
Là beaucoup de marins sont atteints de diarrhée
à cause de l'eau du fleuve, et une vieille
blessure de Philibert se rouvre, mais ça
ne les empêche pas d'herboriser tous les
jours d'après le journal de Philibert:
Ils reprennent enfin la route et mettent encore
deux mois à traverser le détroit de Magellan,
puis trois mois à traverser le Pacifique
vers Tahiti.
Pendant ce temps là, Jeanne et Philibert
cataloguent et trient les specimens qu'ils
ont récoltés tout le long de la côte brésilienne.
Enfin, que Jeanne a récoltés, surtout, parce
qu'à cause de la blessure de Philibert il
passait la plupart de son temps à bord du
navire.
L'arrivée à Tahiti est importante puisque
c'est là que, selon Bougainville, l'identité
de Jeanne est découverte: pour honorer
les visiteurs, les tahitiens leur proposent
de s'unir à des filles locales.
Philibert trouve ça génial, et décrit Tahiti
comme l'île de l'amour, blablabla.
Jeanne est beaucoup plus mesurée et choquée,
parce qu'elle voit bien que les filles en
question ne sont pas vraiment libres de leurs
choix.
En tout cas, d'après Bougainville, un tahitien
nommé Aotourou déclare immédiatement que
c'est une femme et aimerait bien en profiter
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire.
Là forcément, Bougainville est informé
du problème, et la vérité est découverte
même si Jeanne prétend avoir tout manigancé
sans que Philibert ait découvert la vérité,
ce qui est peu probable.
Cet épisode a probablement eu lieu, mais
l'identité de Jeanne était surtout découverte
depuis longtemps.
En racontant que Jeanne a été découverte
par les tahitiens, Bougainville se protège
contre les poursuites qu'il pourrait subir.
Tous les autres témoignages montrent que
Jeanne était soupçonnée d'être une femme
depuis bien plus longtemps: dès les Canaries,
apparemment, l'équipage commençait à douter
d'elle et donc à lui attribuer tous les malheurs
à bord.
Dans le journal de bord de François Vivez
on trouve différentes notes sur elle:
On trouve étrange qu'elle ait de petites
mains, pas de poils au menton...
Elle prétend apparemment être un eunuque
pendant un temps, se met à dormir dans un
hamac avec le reste de l'équipage et à participer
aux manœuvres pour faire taire les soupçons,
mais il est probable qu'une partie de l'équipage
avait bien compris qui elle était bien avant
l'incident de Tahiti.
On ne sait pas, par contre, si Bougainville
était au courant, puisqu'ils étaient dans
deux navires différents.
En tout cas après cette révélation, et
en dépit des risques que ça comporte pour
l'expédition, Bougainville autorise Jeanne
à continuer le voyage habillée en homme
et à arrêter de se bander la poitrine.
L'équipage explore alors la Nouvelle Guinée
et atteint l'Île Maurice en 1768.
Là, Jeanne et Philibert débarque: pour
passer plus de temps à explorer l'île avec
un ami botaniste qui s'y trouvait déjà,
et probablement aussi parce que Philibert
est de plus en plus mal.
Sur cette île, il donne le nom de Baret à
une plante, mais elle est renommée par la
suite par les naturalistes français.
Ils passent encore cinq ans ensemble à botaniser
les îles des environs, se rendent probablement
à Madagascar et à l'île Bourbon ensemble,
mais Philibert Commerson meurt finalement
le 13 mars 1773.
Ironiquement, il est nommé associé de l'Académie
des Sciences six semaines après sa mort.
On ne connaît pas l'emplacement de sa tombe,
mais on sait qu'il avait rédigé son testament
avant de partir: il léguait presque tout
à son fils mais réservait 600 livres et
son appartement pour Jeanne, et lui donnait
pour consigne de mettre en forme ses collections
et de les envoyer au roi en cas de décès,
encore une preuve qu'il estimait son travail
de botaniste.
Elle expédie donc en France les 32 caisses
de fleurs séchées récoltées durant toutes
ces années: 5000 fleurs, dont 3000 nouvelles.
Malheureusement le tout était assez dispersé,
Philibert n'était pas un scientifique très
rigoureux: une partie de ses découvertes
va au museum, d'autres au naturaliste Buffon,
d'autres à des botanistes...
Jeanne ne peut pas embarquer avec les caisses
parce qu'elle n'a pas d'argent, et parce que
pour rentrer en France il faudrait qu'elle
se fasse de nouveau passer pour un homme.
Comme elle est seule et qu'elle ne peut pas
toucher l'argent du testament sans rentrer
en France, elle décide d'ouvrir une auberge.
Là elle rencontre un officier de marine,
Jean Dubernat, qu'elle épouse en 1774 avant
de rentrer en France l'année suivante.
Jeanne est donc la première femme à avoir
fait le tour du monde.
Elle termine ses jours dans le Périgord avec
son mari, mais ne tombe pas dans l'oubli pour
autant: en 1776 elle reçoit l'argent du
testament de Philibert, et à partir de 1785
elle reçoit une pension annuelle de 200 livres
par Louis XVI lui-même, qui reconnaît ses
mérites d'aide-botaniste et la félicite
pour avoir partagé, "avec le plus grand courage,
les travaux et périls" de Commerson.
Pour rappel, Louis XVI qualifie donc de «femme
extraordinaire» une jeune femme issue de
la paysannerie, qui s'était travestie illégalement
pour devenir assistante botaniste dans un
navire royal.
C'est pas mal.
Elle meurt finalement le 5 août 1807 à Saint-Aulaye.
Même si elle a longtemps été oubliée,
une plante grimpante a été nommée solanum
baretiae en son honneur en 2012, plusieurs
livres d'histoire ou romans ont été écrits
à son sujet, et une chaîne de montagnes
est nommée monts Baret en son honneur.
Une chaîne de montagnes sur Pluton.
Ce qui la rend exceptionnelle n’est donc
pas le fait qu’elle se soit travestie pour
braver un interdit, car ce n’était pas
la première femme à le faire, ni son histoire
avec Commerson parce que ça n’avait pas
l’air non plus d’être le grand amour
entre eux: leur relation ressemble plutôt
à une association de botanistes, et plus
si affinités.
Elle n’est pas non plus décrite comme particulièrement
belle dans les divers témoignages qui restent
sur elle.
Bougainville dit d’elle:
Elle a eu la chance de devenir la gouvernante
de Philibert Commerson, d’abord, ce qui
lui permet de se hisser au dessus de sa condition
initiale.
Le reste, qui fait que je l’apprécie, vient
entièrement de son caractère: elle fait
preuve de curiosité scientifique, rêve de
partir à l’aventure dès que l’occasion
se présente malgré les risques que ça comporte…
Auprès de Philibert, elle apprend la botanique
mais aussi l’anatomie, en disséquant par
exemple des poissons, et tout ça fait qu’elle
est qualifiée d’experte en botanique par
Bougainville lui-même.
C’était une scientifique, à une époque
où elles étaient encore rares, et la première
femme à avoir fait le tour du monde.